estamos en la ciudad de isum en la
provincia de como muchas ciudades de
esta provincia fue tomada por las
fuerzas rusas después de esa invasión el
24 de febrero el año pasado después de
una gran batalla fue tomada o retomado
su control por las fuerzas ucranianas
después de esa exitosa contraofensiva
que se dio durante el otoño pero que
también Deja como ejemplo los grandes
retos que tiene Ucrania de Cara a esta
contraofensiva que se planea para los
próximos días o semanas y todo dependerá
de la actitud y de la posición que tomen
las fuerzas de moscús y deciden pelear
por ciudades en el sur la provincia de
saporilla por ejemplo la gran melitopolo
bers la destrucción que puede quedar es
más o menos como esta como la que vemos
en una en esta ciudad una de las más
destruidas
desde entonces hay otro ejemplo como el
que sucedió en la ciudad de gersón
cuando las tropas rusas decidieron
retirarse después de la presión de las
tropas ucranianas Así que esta
destrucción este grado de pérdidas
materiales como las que se ve en esta
ciudad y en muchas partes de la
provincia será uno de esos grandes retos
y también una de las grandes dudas que
vamos a despejar en las próximas semanas
y meses cuando realmente se conozca Cuál
será el éxito
de esta contraofensiva ucraniana Y cómo
realmente será la actitud y la respuesta
de